all right okay all right
all right okay all right i'm moving on
yep andy cohen might just be over the
current cast of the real housewives of
orange county
let's break this down is it ever a
thought like maybe we just kind of scrap
what we already shot
and start from quarantine on because
you know life is so different great
stuff shot i don't
i don't think we want to lose anything
that is what andy told us last spring
before rhoc finished filming
but after a season sidelined by the
coronavirus pandemic
they have shut the entire
country down they're stopping production
you're supposed to be
six feet apart and peppered with
controversial comments
off the show remember when we had two
more kids and our parents are like you
can't go outside
oh you're like oh just go get the
chicken pox i mean kind of don't we kind
of feel like
that right now or do you just go out
there and just get it
fans are calling for a change when
culture writer evan ross katz tweeted it
was time to cancel the series
housewives superfan megan mccain replied
in agreement
which elicited this response from the
housewife boss
i think you mean reboot you go through
peaks and valleys
rhoc just finished its 15th season
it's the og of the franchise and it's
unlikely it goes off the air
anytime soon but there's definitely
something amiss with the current cast
their inability to get along might make
a 16th season
hard to film i know i
i know i cannot film with bronwyn i know
for a fact i can't i cannot film with
her
there's just no way and if she comes
back then
i i'm out because i i
i i know for a fact i cannot she's
dangerous
yeah pretty much everyone on the show
seems over bronwyn windham burke
i'm the only one here that's like uh
we're all down here should i bow to you
and she's
well feeling the same way about them
there isn't anyone on this cast i can
turn to when it comes to
you know how i feel vocally how i feel
about
black lives matter how i feel about
lgbtqi rights there's
no one on this cast that i can turn to
that interview bite
actually made its way to the show during
part two of the reunion
[Music]
so where do we go from here it's likely
some or at least
one of the current cast return for
season 16
and there's always a chance for a
comeback i have to say tamra is
she's so real and she always keeps it
real
she's been in such an incredible part of
the show for 12 years
that my only thing that i'll say about
her is you have not seen the last of
tamra on the outsides of orange county
she may not know it you may not know it
but do you want to tell her do you want
to tell her tamra
we love you we're not totally done
tamara judge who was outside from the
show after season 14
is kind of sorta angling for a return
check out
this tick tock she made after being
mentioned in pretty much
every episode of season 15. despite
not getting a paycheck
[Music]
seen sunny days times when i could not
find a friend
but i always thought i'd see you
[Music]
again